Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Hast du dein Twitter-Account schon gelöscht?
Nee, ich hab doch meinen Mastodon-Account verlinkt. dann wird Twitter den jetzt eh bald für mich löschen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 448 vom 18.12.2022.
Das Jahr ändert sich, nein es ändert sich nicht, es endet sich langsam.
Das Jahr ändert sich der Nähe zu...
Oh Gott, ist alles durcheinander. Ja, es weihnachtet schon fast sehr.
Wir nähern uns sehr der Frage, wann wir die letzte Sendung des Jahres machen. Das ist, glaube ich, noch nicht vielleicht.
Vielleicht hoffentlich noch nicht. Eine versuchen wir noch.
Ja, vielleicht hoffentlich noch nicht. Wir kriegen aber sicherlich noch hin, wenn das alles so klappt, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Ja, so sieht's aus.
Gucken, ob's da Twitter noch gibt.
Oder uns auf Twitter noch gibt. Ist doch auch noch unklar. Ja.
Boah, das ist ja so ein... Das ist so irgendwie...
Dickhead, fragile Ego.
Wir wollten ja nicht über die WM reden, aber Elon Musk erinnert mich gerade so ein bisschen
an Zinedine Zidane.
Der hätte einfach nur nichts machen müssen und wäre okay gewesen, weißt du?
Aber der rennt da rum, headbuttet irgendwelche Leute und wundert sich, dass er nicht so viel.
Ja, über die WM meinst du?
Verständnis dafür erntet.
Aber wir werden gleich noch darüber sprechen. Wer sehr viel Verständnis geerntet hat, ist die Kabul-Luftbrücke.
Wir sind also gerade sehr erstaunt gewesen über unsere Spendenaktion dort.
Die letzte Sendung ist am 12.12. veröffentlicht worden. Und nur sechs Stunden nach Veröffentlichung der Sendung, die ja drei Stunden lang war,
wir das Spendenziel von 1000 Euro schon erreicht und haben dann jetzt regelmäßig das Spendenziel erhöht, bis wir jetzt zum Zeitpunkt der Aufzeichnung über 8000 Euro zusammen haben.
Das ist sehr, sehr erfreulich und ich denke, bei der Kabel-Lufbrucke ist es gut aufgehoben und ich möchte allen danken.
Das hat wirklich alle Erwartungen, die ich hatte, übertroffen, dass wir da so viel Geld zusammenbekommen haben.
Ja, Superaktionen. Auch wenn jetzt die Leute natürlich nicht für uns spenden. Aber ist okay.
Ja, wir sind auch nicht in Kabul. Insofern geht das schon klar. Aber du hast dir dann doch noch was einfallen lassen, Tim.
Nee, das stimmt.
Ja, schon länger eigentlich. Genau.
Es ist tatsächlich seit Monaten eine schwere Geburt hier. Wir haben daraus gelernt, dass wir uns das aufsetzen, neue Merches einfach sehr früh in den Kalender setzen müssen, weil es sehr viel länger dauert, als man meint.
Das ist dumm gelaufen.
Ich bin immer so überrascht vom Ende des Jahres. Das kommt für mich, das überwältigt mich. Auf einmal habe ich Geburtstag und dann geht auf einmal alles ganz schnell und dann kommen wir schon nicht mehr mal hinterher.
Ja, das ist schlimm. Ich sitze mir im Kalender. Aber wir hatten vor, euch nochmal ein Angebot zu machen, für uns zu werben. Genau, sehr eindrücklich und genau. Und.
Für uns zu werben.
Jetzt gibt es ein neues T-Shirt und es gibt es gleich auch noch als Hoodie.
Mit dem wunderbaren Logo der Einhorn-Standarte. Erfahrene LMP-Hörerinnen erinnern sich sicherlich.
Wir hatten im November 2017 unsere Sendung mit diesem Thema der AfD Totenkopfstandate.
Die das Zentrum für politische Schönheit bedroht hat.
Die hatten damals das Stehlen-Mahn mal in Höckes Nachbargarten gebaut und daraufhin haben sie einen Anruf bekommen von jemandem, der sich ausgab als Mitglied der AfD Totenkopfstandarte,
Und den Philipp Ruch, glaube ich.
Auf jeden Fall war das alles ausreichend absurd, sodass wir da unsere Witze drüber
gemacht haben.
Und das war dann so ein bisschen auch der Geburt der Einhorn-Standarte. Und dann dauerte es auch nicht lange und von Jan Willhaus kam dann nämlich ein lustiges
Design mit einem kleinen Einhorn.
Was diese Einhorn-Standarte das erste Mal visualisiert hat.
Das fanden wir schon mal ganz gut und ganz lustig.
Da haben wir auch irgendwie Aufkleber mal von gemacht. Und dann dauerte es noch mal ein paar Wochen später,
als jemand namens Krimp daraus dann irgendwie ein noch irreres Logo gemacht hat.
Mit diesem, ja, wie soll man das nennen? Hast du Worte dafür?
Das ist ein Punk-Hooligan-Einhorn mit unterschiedlichen Tätowierungen und einer Fahne in der Hand,
auf der dann das Logo ist, was vorher der Jan gemacht hatte. Und genau, dieses Punk-Hooligan-Einhorn mit so einem Regenbogen-Irokesenschnitt und so.
Das haben wir, also ich habe mir das schon mal zur Flagge gemacht und die mal aufgehängt.
Hatten wir das nicht auch bei einer unserer Livesendungen? Ne, doch, natürlich.
Hm...
Wir hatten das bei einer der Livesendungen auch am Babylon hängen und ich glaube auf
dem Camp 2019 hingen das dann auch nochmal.
So ein ganz großes, jaja. Ich weiß, dass du sich an so Dinge nicht erinnerst, deswegen erzähle ich dir das.
Erinnere ich nicht mehr genau.
Naja, ist schön. Du, seitdem ich Alzheimer habe, lade ich jeden Tag neue Leute kennen.
Es ist immer wieder schön, was man da für Freude damit machen kann.
Ich glaube, das ist das Einzige, wie man es in diesem Hamsterrad der Netzpolitik langfristig aushält.
Das hilft generell.
Genau, aber das gibt es jetzt in wunderschönem Digitaldruck zu bestellen auf T-Shirt und Hoodie.
Die. Und damit haben wir dann nämlich auch noch eine Bitte.
Und du kannst mal in Spamfilter gucken oder so.
Genau, bitte melde dich. Wir haben nämlich versucht mal mit Grimp irgendwie Kontakt aufzunehmen und es ist uns bisher nicht gelungen.
Vielleicht hörst du das ja noch, hier dieses Programm und könntest ja dich kurz mal mit Piep bei uns melden und wir würden dir gerne ein paar T-Shirts
vorbeischicken.
Also mehrere Kontaktversuche auf verschiedenen Kanälen haben in letzter Zeit.
Genau, wir kennen nur deinen Twitter-Account und das war es dann auch. Da gab es keine Reaktion.
Genau, für alle anderen gibt es das Shirt und den Hoodie zu bestellen. Und natürlich nicht mehr vor Weihnachten. Boah, es sieht aber wirklich gut aus.
Das ist wirklich gut. Das ist so richtig toll.
Deswegen hat es auch lange so lang gedauert, weil ich halt noch die Samples vorher haben wollte in der richtigen Größe.
Und dann sind die in der Post verloren gegangen und dann mussten die nochmal gesendet werden.
Dauerte alles und dann ging das so in diese Weihnachtslogistik rein und hat dann einfach
so eine irre Verzögerung gehabt. Von daher können wir euch da jetzt wenig Hoffnungen
machen, weil das müsste eigentlich zu diesem Zeitpunkt, wo wir diese Sendung aufnehmen
müssen, es eigentlich schon eingetütet sein, wenn es noch irgendeine Chance haben sollte.
Aber naja, egal, dann ist halt kein Weihnachtsgeschenk. Genau. Dann halt nächstes Jahr.
Zu Weihnachten kommt es nicht mehr. Das ist klar, aber man will ja auch im neuen Jahr was haben.
Neujahrs-Hoodie.
Ja, auch das nächste Jahr wird ja ganz toll.
So, und dann muss man auch passend gekleidet sein.
Das ist auf jeden Fall die richtige Kleidung für den...
Für die goldenen Zwanziger. All right, links findet ihr natürlich in den Show Notes alles auf shop.metaebene.me.
Das ist auf jeden Fall die richtige Kleidung für die goldenen Zwanziger.
So Feedback haben wir auch noch bekommen, vor allem zum Warentag.
Also natürlich nicht generell zum Warntag an sich, sondern zu dem, was wir darüber.
Ja gut, Warntag hat natürlich auch alle beschäftigt.
Das ist klar, dass du viel Feedback bekommst.
Also... Das habe ich nicht gemut, das weiß ich.
Gesagt und behauptet haben. Und es gab sehr unterschiedliche Erfahrungen offenbar da draußen.
Zunächst einmal hattest du ja gemutmaßt, dass man ja noch mit einem simkartenlosen
Telefon einen Notruf absetzen kann.
Und dass man sich für diesen Notruf mit einer Zelle verbindet auch.
Und was ich mir nicht sicher war, ist, ob das Telefon das auch wirklich schon sofort tut
oder erst wenn man den Notruf braucht. Aber auch da war ich mir relativ sicher, dass es das sofort tut.
Und bei der Gelegenheit bekommst du dann im Zweifelsfall auch ganz einfach Cellbroadcast. Aber da war ich mir nicht sicher.
Also du gehst nach wie vor davon aus, dass dem so sei, weil anderes Feedback,
berichtete uns, dass sei in Deutschland deaktiviert worden.
Dass also Notruf mit Telefon ohne SIM-Karte nicht mehr möglich ist.
Das kann ich mir schwer vorstellen.
Wo steht das? Kannst du mir den Kommentar zeigen?
Nein kann ich nicht, weil ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht gerade sicher bin. Ich habe auf verschiedensten Kanälen, Leute bitte schreibt das immer in die Kommentare rein.
Aber ich bin irgendwie über Twitter und E-Mail und so weiter, jetzt kann ich es gerade nicht mehr sagen. Ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen erst mal zu Beginn eine Melange aus all dem, was ich so einzeln,
gehört habe. Viele haben dann auch berichtet, dass sie halt auch mit Telefonen zumindest ohne SIM-Karte auch,
Warnungen erhalten haben, dann aber auf alten Telefonen teilweise nichts bekommen haben. Weil offenbar sieht es so aus, dass wohl dieser Sell-Broadcast, der in Deutschland zum Einsatz kommt, mit älteren Telefonen nicht mehr kompatibel ist.
Das kann sein, dass wir irgendwas gemacht haben.
Ich habe da was in Erinnerung mit irgendwie ein Byte mehr und das Ganze ist dann sozusagen ein neurer Standard, der nur von neueren Telefonen unterstützt wird.
Man hat also da kein Fallback für ganz alte Telefone gemacht, warum auch immer.
Naja. Und dann gab es noch ganz viel Feedback zu, wie denn diese Ränen denn so in Deutschland
zum Einsatz kommen und was denn nun wirklich ein Testsignal ist und was nicht.
Und das ist natürlich unterschiedlich nach Bundesland.
Ist es total durcheinander und das hat alles auch so ein bisschen seine Gründe darin, wie dieses ganze System,
Anfang der 90er Jahre, weil es ja keine Bedrohung mehr gibt, weil Katakrieg ist ja vorbei, also brauchen wir auch keine Sirenen mehr, wie das so,
vonstatten ging. Dazu lese ich einfach mal den informativen Kommentar von STK vor, ein bisschen länger ist, aber den wir hier trotzdem mal mit einbauen wollen, das erklärt das eine oder andere.
So ist das auch in vielen anderen ländlichen Regionen. Die Sirenen gehörten ursprünglich fast alle dem Staat im Westen, dem Warndienst bzw. den Warnämtern des Bundes und wurden meist sowohl für die Alarmierung der Feuerwehren als auch für den Bevölkerungsschutz verwendet.
Nach der Wende dachte man, man könne mit dem Kram nichts mehr anfangen und hat die Sirene in der Regel an die jeweilige Kommune abgegeben, innerhalb derer, die so auf den Dächern rumlungerten. Dort wurde sie dann teilweise bis heute entweder als Rückfallebene zur Pager-Alarmierung oder in kleineren Gemeinden bis heute als Primär-Alarmierung der Feuerwehr verwendet.
Also dann freiwillige Feuerwehr. Es gibt auch Orte, wo der Probealarm einfach nur einmal die
Sirene kurz hochfährt und wieder runterlaufen lässt. Es geht ja nur darum, herauszufinden, ob das Motor schützt tut und der Motor noch dreht und noch nicht so viele Vögel drin listen. Und,
Viel von der aktuellen Misere der Wiederaktivierung kommt genau aus diesem Hin und Her und dass es ultra-diffuse Zuständigkeiten gab.
Irgendwann Ende der 90er fiel auf, dass es zwar jetzt keinen gehalten Krieg und kurzstreckend Atomwaffen mehr direkt vor der Tür gab,
man aber unter anderem im Rahmen der Störfallverordnung ja trotzdem noch diverse Gefahren hat, vor denen man warnen muss.
Die Warnämter gab es in dem Sinn dann aber nicht mehr.
Da mussten dann teilweise Sirenensteuergeräte ersetzt werden, weil man bei der letzten Aktualisierung,
die Möglichkeit zur Auslösung eines Heultons wegrationalisiert hatte.
Oder man musste einen Sammelruf für alle Sirenen eines Landkreises einführen, um die überhaupt gleichzeitig auslösen zu können, weil die Alternative war, jede bei der Alarmauslösung
per Funk einzeln zu adressieren, was für einen gesamten Landkreis dann mal 10 bis 15 Minuten
dauern kann, bis man alle durch hat. Die Sirenen sind aber nur ein Nebenkriegsschauplatz eigentlich, weil die Sirenen sollen dir klassischerweise
bedeuten, dass du jetzt einen Rundfunkempfänger anschalten und auf Durchsagen warten sollst.
Das Problem ist nur, dass der Pfad, woher weiß der Rundfunk, was er sagen soll, nie,
über eher akademische Nachbauversuche des US Emergency Alert System hinausgekommen sind.
Ich habe das mal live miterlebt, als in einer Leitstelle irgendwann in der Nacht zum Samstag bei der Schichtübergabe, der eigentlich für Samstagmittag vorgesehene Sirenenalarm direkt,
scharf geschaltet wurde, anstatt ihn nur für die nächste Schicht vorzubereiten.
Und weil in dem Landkreis alle drei Monate der Heulton stand, das Feuerwehralarm getestet wird, wurde so nachts um 2 Uhr ungerade der halbe Landkreis per Sirene geweckt und gebeten,
das Radio einzuschalten. Blöderweise kommt um die Uhrzeit halt auch in den öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender die
Musik einfach nur aus der Konserve und da erreißt du halt telefonisch gar niemanden. Und wenn die Polizei die Tür eintritt, findet sie vielleicht eine Hausmeisterin, die auch,
nicht genau weiß, was man da als Radio sagt. So gesehen ja eindrucksvoll letztes Jahr in Wuppertal, als die Talsperre überlief und
nur ein kleines freies Radio-Onair blieb. Die Frage, wer einem sagen kann, was eigentlich Phase ist, so lokal bei sich in der Kommune
oder im Bezirk und welche Gedanken, die sich bislang gemacht haben und wie fit die generell sind bei sowas, sind super gute Fragen für die interessierte Bürgerin, die einfach gerne Fragen stellt und Sicherheit und gefühlte Sicherheit auseinanderdividieren will.
Ich habe währenddessen mal kurz gegoogelt und tatsächlich hat in Deutschland offenbar der Bundesrat 2009 eine Verordnung erlassen,
dass Handys ohne SIM keine Notrufe mehr absetzen dürfen und der absetzen können dürfen. Und der Hintergrund ist, dass es offenbar zu viel Missbrauch gab.
Genau.
Ja krass, war mir tatsächlich nicht bekannt. Ja, this is why we can't have nice things.
Gerade so, ich würde eigentlich sagen, gerade so 2000, vielleicht noch so bis 2012, 15
wäre es echt noch vielleicht sinnvoll gewesen, einem alten Handy irgendeiner Person zu geben.
Andererseits, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, kann ich mir auch echt vorstellen, dass so in der Regel nicht unbedingt,
also gerade heute hat man wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt ein Mobilfunktelefon ohne SIM dabei,
sodass es potenziell verständlich ist, dass eine solche ursprünglich mal sinnvolle Funktionalität,
dann doch ja entfernt wird oder unterbunden wird.
Ja, es gibt immer jemand, der irgendwie die elektrischen Roller in den See schmeißt.
Ja, dann hatten wir ein paar Witze gemacht über Chat-GPT, ohne dass wir das Thema eigentlich so groß auf die Agenda gesetzt hatten, weil wir das im Wesentlichen eigentlich erstmal auch
alles etwas erlustigend fanden, was da so stattgefunden hat. Wurden dann allerdings von verschiedenen Seiten angesprochen. Ja, dass man das doch jetzt, keine Ahnung.
Zum Ernsthaftigkeit ermahnt. Zum Apokalypse.
Was so genau die Erwartungshaltung war, weil wir hätten da irgendwie nicht ausreichend
Stellung bezogen oder so, wo ich halt sagen muss, das ist halt ein komplexes Feld. Diese ganze AI-Machine Learning-Geschichte entwickelt sich sehr schnell und ist natürlich vollkommen klar, dass das jetzt gerade eine der dynamischsten und wichtigsten Technologien ist, auf denen sich Sachen entscheiden.
Chat-GPT ist halt nur ein Ding da drin und wird sicherlich jetzt nicht irgendwie
die dominante Technologie der Zukunft sein, aber das breitet sich halt überall aus. Und mit solchen Sachen ist es halt immer so, das hat Chancen und das hat Risiken.
Und beides abzuwägen ist glaube ich hier auch so ein bisschen unser Auftrag und,
Technologie ist nicht per se schlecht, sondern aus sowas wie JetGPT können halt
tolle Sachen dabei rauskommen, aber es können auch total blöde Sachen dabei
rauskommen. Das lässt sich derzeit auch nur sehr eingeschränkt abschätzen, was
das jetzt genau sein wird. Auf keinen Fall sollte man so einer Technologie einfach blind vertrauen
und sagen, oh jetzt kriege ich hier irgendwelche Antworten, da muss ich jetzt nur dobe Fragen
reinstellen, dann wird das schon alles stimmen. Also gerade so was, so Hausaufgabendiskussionen
und so weiter betrifft. Es kann halt auch einfach alles komplett falsch sein, was dabei,
rauskommt. Es kann aber auch alles komplett richtig sein, was dabei rauskommt. Man kann das auch einfach als Inspirationswerkzeug verwenden, sagen irgendwie mal mal was, so
jetzt in Text gedacht. Und dann kann man darauf auch aufbauen.
Und dann ist das irgendwie auch eine total legitime Anwendung, wie ich finde. Also, glaube ich, ein bisschen zu früh, hier irgendwas pauschal abzuwatschen.
Es geht ja in den Kommentaren nicht nur um das pauschale Abwatschen.
Die großen Gefahren der AI lassen sich eigentlich relativ schnell zusammenfassen in diesem Computer-Sense-No-Phänomen. Es wird Menschen immer schwieriger, oder es bedeutet mehr Aufwand, das, was die AI oder der Computer vorschlägt, nicht zu machen.
Die Entscheidungsfindung, die Arbeit selber zu machen.
Dann geht es natürlich auch um eine Verfügbarkeit. Dieses Unternehmen stellt da halt mal so ein Chatbot ein zum Spaß zur Verfügung.
Der wird potenziell nicht kostenfrei bleiben. Das heißt, da wird es dann auch die Fragen des Zugangs zu der Technologie geben.
Das ist alles richtig. Das wird immer so sein.
Oder was heißt das wird immer so sein, das wird ja doch vermutlich so bleiben erstmal,
dass neue Technologien ja nicht allen zur Verfügung gestellt werden und bzw. dass
sie finanziert werden müssen, refinanziert werden müssen und so weiter und so fort.
Denke über diese über diese Debatten werden wir dann hier die nächsten Jahre sprechen.
Aber das sind in der Regel keine Debatten, die notwendigerweise mit der Technologie zu tun haben.
Ich glaube, das ist, was du ja auch gerade sagen möchtest, Tim, sondern mit der Gestaltung,
wie wir als Gesellschaft dann damit umgehen. Und deswegen hätte ich ehrlich gesagt, zu diesem Zeitpunkt jetzt keinen Anlass, in irgendeine dieser Richtungen zu verfallen.
Das wird spannend, jetzt kommt mal was Neues und wir werden eine ganze Menge bekloppte Dinge sehen, die damit passieren. Positive Dinge, negative Dinge, kritische Sachen und so weiter.
Das werden wir jetzt einfach die nächsten Jahre diskutieren, aber das macht sich jetzt, glaube ich, nicht daran fest, dass man das jetzt alles an Chat-GPT festmachen muss, oder?
Nee, das ist halt auch jetzt erstmal nur wieder so ein Ding, was halt schön zeigt, so ah, okay, man ist jetzt wieder mal einen Schritt gegangen in dieser ganzen Entwicklung und es hat wieder so einen Awesomeness-Effekt, wie das ja vorher auch schon mit diesen generierten Bildern war,
die wir auch schon mal gesprochen hatten. Da werden sicherlich noch ein paar andere Effekte kommen. Nebenbei wird auf der mit derselben Technik werden jetzt auch,
unsere Podcast transkribiert zum Beispiel. Also es basiert auf derselben Technologie oder zumindest ein Teil dieser Technologie. Da ist es ja dann auch ganz,
hilfreich. Also ist mal schwierig so etwas pauschal zu bewerten. Im Einzelnen
kann man das schon machen. Aber da gerade die ganze Hausaufgabendiskussion hochkam, zitiere ich noch mal einen lustigen Kommentar von Florian zu dem Thema. Er schreibt um zum,
Thema KI und Hausaufgaben eine Geschichte, die ich loswerden muss, um mein Gewissen zu erleichtern. Am Ende meiner Schulzeit gab es noch keine Online-Übersetzer. Allerdings,
gab es Software zum Kaufen dafür. Ich wollte meine Abschlussnote in Englisch verbessern
und fragte die Lehrerin nach einer zusätzlichen Leistung, die ich erbringen könnte. Also sollte ich einen Aufsatz schreiben. Das tat ich. Auf Deutsch. Dann kopierte ich den Text in ein Übersetzungstool, zu meinem Glück eine 30 Tage Sherwär-Version und gab schließlich zwei A4-Seiten ab. Areal, Schriftgröße 10.
Wo unten drunter stand, von welcher Software das ist, wahrscheinlich, oder?
Weiß ich nicht. Die waren schlecht. Wirklich schlecht. Das Tool war die reinste Katastrophe.
Aber genau deshalb meinte meine Lehrerin erkannt zu haben, dass ich das tatsächlich selbst
geschrieben haben musste und gab mir eine gute Note, einfach für meinen Fleiß und den Willen mich zu verbessern.
Das erinnert an dieses wunderschöne, kennst du doch auch dieses, das ist ein uraltes Bild, aber so ein Messestand, wo jemand quasi für sein Produkt da irgendwie wirft.
Da sind halt ein paar chinesische Schriftzeichen und da drüber steht einfach noch mal in englischer Sprache,
Translation Error.
Das waren halt die frühen KI-Systeme. Du kannst einen Translation Error kaufen.
Das ist auch ein sehr schönes.
Ja, schön. Also ich glaube, hier im Quality Land von Marc-Uwe Kling gibt es
auch so eine Situation, wo das Captcha irgendwann andersrum ist. Wo man sagt,
die Captchas erkennen am Ende die Menschen an ihren dummen Fehlern. Also anfangs wurden
die Captchas gemacht, damit du der künstlichen Intelligenz was beibringst. Irgendwann überholt die dich und jetzt erkennen sie dich daran, dass du die Aufgabe nicht mehr lösen kannst.
Oder so niedlich dumme Fehler machst, oder so lange Brauchst und solche Dinge.
Ja, kann schon sein.
So, dann hatte ich kurz von der neuen Advanced Data Protection von Apple's iCloud gesprochen.
Dazu nochmal ein kurzer Nachtrag, weil ich sagte, das gibt's jetzt schon. Dabei hatte ich kurz übersehen, dass es erst mal nur in den USA freigeschaltet ist,
und in Deutschland, also überhaupt anderen Ländern und unter anderem wohl auch in Deutschland Deutschland wohl erst im Laufe des Frühjahrs kommen soll, wird man dann sehen, also sie rollen das sozusagen schrittweise aus. Gibt auch ein bisschen Kritik an der Umsetzung,
weil zum Beispiel dort eine Technologie zum Einsatz kommt namens Convergent Encryption.
Das soll sicherstellen, dass man, obwohl die Inhalte als solche nicht sichtbar sind, man immerhin noch doppelte Daten feststellen kann. Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel fünfmal dasselbe Foto in seiner Datenbank drin hat und das Foto wird dann verschlüsselt abgelegt.
Dann entsteht daraus ein Hash-Wert, so eine kurze Zusammenfassung, die dann bei allen
fünf identischen Bildern auch identisch ist, sodass man serverseitig, auch wenn man den Inhalt nicht sieht, noch sagen kann, okay, das ist jetzt hier fünfmal drin, das müssen jetzt auch nicht fünf mal speichern, sondern speichern wir nur einmal. Theoretisch lässt
sowas halt dann wiederum so Angriffe zu, dass man daran quasi Bilder dann auch wiedererkennen kann,
die da drin sind. Also wir hatten ja diese ganze Diskussion mit CSAM. Das wird sich glaube ich
noch zeigen in dieser ganzen Diskussion, ist aber wahrscheinlich erstmal nebensächlich.
Verschiedene Leute hatten dann noch nachgefragt, warum denn jetzt nicht die gesamte iCloud,
sondern eben mit Ausnahme von den drei Diensten, E-Mail, Kalender und Contacts, also warum die
rausgenommen sind. Und der Grund ist schlicht, dass E-Mail ist einfach generell als Dienst,
unverschüsselt. Also wenn Apple eure E-Mail hostet und ihr unverschüsselte Mail empfängt,
dann muss die ja auf diesem Server irgendwie abgespeichert werden und kann dann nicht nochmal
verschlüsselt werden. Und ähnliche Gründe gibt es bei Kalender und Contacts, weil die ja dann
auch öffentlich geschert werden können über solche Protokolle wie Kaldav und Carddav und die.
Sehen so in der aktuellen Form Verschlüsselung nicht vor. Das heißt nicht, dass das nicht in
Zukunft irgendwann nochmal geändert werden könnte, aber zumindest ist es halt zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Das ist natürlich ein generelles Problem, gerade bei E-Mail. Das haben wir ja
schon immer gesehen, dass Verschlüsselung und E-Mail, das ist irgendwie etwas, was nicht so
richtig zusammenkommt. Es gibt seit Ewigkeiten GPG, seit wann gibt es das jetzt irgendwie? Seit Anfang der 90er oder wann? Naja, aber das kommt halt einfach alles nicht vom Fleck.
Ich fühl mich auch nicht, auf jeden Fall.
Weil es halt einfach zu kompliziert ist, das Ganze zu handhaben etc. Es gibt einen Verschlüsselungsstandard,
der heißt SMIME, aber der wird halt auch kaum benutzt, weil du auch da noch Aufwand hast mit Zertifikaten
und wenn überhaupt nur so im Business Kontext überhaupt irgendwie relevant.
S-MIME funktioniert schon ganz gut.
Es gibt natürlich Fehlimplementationen bei iCloud, Outlook und solchen Dingen.
Aber bei E-Mail hast du das grundsätzliche Problem, dass das eben nicht standardmäßig mit drin ist. diese ganzen, also SMIME und PGP, sind Verschlüsselungssysteme für den Anwendungsfall
E-Mail, die aber vollständig getrennt davon funktionieren. Sie sind nicht Teil des Standards
E-Mail. Du kannst also sagen, ich habe einen E-Mail-Client mit voller Funktionalität und auch,
eine E-Mail-Adresse mit voller Funktionalität und keinen PGP oder kein S-Mime. Und das hat
natürlich die Verbreitung so stark eingeschränkt, dass es nicht Teil des tatsächlichen Messaging-Standards
ist, so wie es dann eben bei Signal oder Threema oder WhatsApp, wo alles aus einem Guss, aber
aber auch von einer Anbieterin kommt, umgesetzt werden kann.
Google will jetzt erst mal zumindest in seinen Enterprise-Gmail einbauen.
Also noch nicht unbedingt für alle, aber eben zumindest da.
Weiß man nicht, ob das eine große Auswirkung hat. Das wird wahrscheinlich alles noch ewig auf sich warten lassen und am Ende glaube ich, ist E-Mail auch nicht mehr heilbar.
Also das Google da jetzt irgendwie, das ist ja sehr eine Nullmeldung. Können die ruhig machen, aber das ist alles Quatsch.
Also für ausgewählte Kunden gibt es irgendwie nach Antrag, irgendwie kriegt man da Verschlüsselung oder so. Das wird Quatsch.
Du kannst das mit jedem Mail-Client machen, auch mit einer Gmail-Adresse. Das ist alles unsinnfältig.
Kommen wir lieber zur Chat-Kontrolle.
Du meinst, das ist kein Unsinn?
Doch, das ist auch absoluter Unsinn. Ich habe das ja hier in der Sendung eigentlich auch immer wieder angemerkt, dass das Innenministerium,
jetzt auf EU-Ebene, also im Rat, die Chatkontrolle aushandelt und dass ich,
vorsichtig davor warne, dass es in diesem Bereich keine personellen Änderungen im Innenministerium gab, dass da halt noch die guten alten Boys sitzen,
und außerdem die Nancy Faeser jetzt nicht ganz so firm,
scheint in den technischen Fragen. Und dass ich da ja seit Längerem den Eindruck habe, dass der Unterbau im Innenministerium einfach macht, was er will und sich nicht davon beeindrucken lässt,
was den Koalitionsvertrag angeht oder so. Weil da ist jetzt irgendwie so ein altgedienter
Cyber-Söldner im BMI, auch ein Fizzerien, nicht daran gebunden, wenn so eine neue Innenministerin Kommuneuinministerin geht. Da hat jetzt Netzpolitik Org vor fünf Tagen, Markus Reuter und André Meister
waren, dass das Positionspapier des Innenministeriums veröffentlicht, wo.
Erkennbar ist, dass am Client-Site Scanning festgehalten werden soll.
Also genau das, was das große Problem ist, der Scanner auf jedem Endgerät potentiell eingebaut in die jeweilige App oder vielleicht sogar ins Betriebssystem, um da eine vollständige Abdeckung zu erreichen.
Und da hat das Innenministerium entgegen den Vereinbarungen mit den Koalitionspartnerinnen,
weiterhin darauf hingearbeitet.
Dann haben wir als CCC, haben wir Viktor eine schöne Pressemitteilung geschrieben, haben
gesagt, so SPD ist, wie man sich erwarten kann, umgekippt, jetzt liegt es halt an der FDP.
Dann müssen jetzt eben das BMDV und BMJ hier sich dagegen positionieren und müssen die
Innenministerin einhegen, weil irgendwofür hat man ja nur mal einen Koalitionsvertrag
geschrieben, irgendwofür hat man ja Wahlversprechen gemacht. Und dann wurde also jetzt ganz schnell
ganz schön starker Druck auf Nancy Feser aufgebaut, die dann irgendwie in der
Bundespressekonferenz gefragt wurde, was sie denn da so macht. Und dann hat sie
gesagt, sie will ja kein kleines Zettel scannen, sie will sich dem ja nur annähern.
Und du denkst so, was heißt hier annähern? Und dann gab es eine
Reihe an Tweets zum Beispiel von Marco Buschmann, Justizminister. Nach einem guten Gespräch mit meiner Kollegin Nancy Feser, kann ich klar sagen, die Bundesregierung ist sich einig, dass wir klar gegen die Chatkontrolle sind. Eine.
Anlasslose Überwachung privater Kommunikation hat in Rechtsstadt nichts zu suchen. Anne Roth hat dann natürlich auch angemerkt, naja, da kommt wieder dieses
Anlass los und da hat Frau Feser ja auch ganz lustige Anlassideen, wenn sie sich für die Vorratshandelsspeicherung einsetzt. Also muss man jetzt mal
vorsichtig sein, ob diese Kuh wirklich vom Eis ist. Aber immerhin, es hat jetzt mal den notwendigen Ruck gegeben, dass sich hier jetzt mal die FDP ernsthaft mit Nancy Faeser
auseinandersetzt, das KS mal ernsthaft mit Nancy Faeser auseinandersetzt und vor allem.
Dass jetzt mal endlich jemand guckt, was die Fachseite und unter Nancy Faeser, da seit Monaten veranstaltet, ohne sich um irgendetwas zu kümmern, was potenziell vielleicht im Koalitionsvertrag steht.
Insofern finde ich schon ganz positiv, dass es zu dieser Eskalation gekommen ist.
Aber die Kuh ist, glaube ich, nicht wirklich vom Eis. Es gibt ja noch weitere Probleme, zum Beispiel die Alterskontrolle, die mit dieser CSA-Verordnung,
einhergeht. Und wollen wir mal schauen. hat dann außerdem in dieser Woche mal wieder einen Fahndungserfolg. Und auch wieder ohne Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ohne Chatkontrolle.
Deswegen, das nennt sich FESA, dann erst mal hingegangen hat, wieder Vorratsdatenspeicherung gefordert. Das ist also wirklich alles schwierig.
Kriegen die denn da eigentlich in dem Moment, wo man jetzt so Innenminister oder Innenministerin wird?
Wirst du dann in so einen Raum geführt, so Türen werden zugemacht und dann so,
Roll that Film. Dann kriegst du irgendwas gezeigt, was du nie wieder aus deinem Kopf kriegst und dann denkst du nicht mehr so wie vorher. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich denke, Innenministerium ist die Verantwortung, also die Situation selber.
Wenn du im Innenministerium weißt, irgendwann wird es wieder Probleme geben. Es wird wieder einen Terroranschlag geben, der dann schon mal nicht verhindert wurde,
der wird dann vielleicht aufgeklärt oder nicht.
Aber dann möchtest du, wenn das passiert, nicht da stehen und auf irgendwelche Maßnahmen verzichtet haben.
Du möchtest nicht, dann dir vorwerfen lassen, weil du keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung gemacht hast, ist das jetzt passiert.
Oder weil du keine Chatkontrolle gemacht hast, ist das jetzt passiert.
Ob das am Ende wirklich etwas bringt oder nicht, ist eigentlich völlig egal. Weil du weißt, so oder so kommt ja das nächste schwere Verbrechen.
Aber dann willst du wenigstens sagen, du hast alles versucht. Und dann machst du natürlich irgendwelche üblen Dinge, damit niemand nachher sagt,
die Fesa hat sich aber keine Mühe gegeben. Dann kannst du sagen, ich habe die ganze Zeit für die Vorurtsdatenspeicherung gekämpft.
Nur weil wir die Vorurtsdatenspeicherung nicht hatten, ist jetzt wieder ein Terroranschlag gekommen.
Dann weißt du auch schon, dass hier die ganzen Springer dich kaputt hetzen und so weiter.
Also machst du halt irgendeine Symbolpolitik über irgendwelchen Quatsch, damit man denkt, du greifst hart durch. Und wenn dann was passiert, kannst du wenigstens sagen...
Also ich glaube, die bilden sich ein, sich damit kaufen zu können, dass sie dann, wenn etwas passiert sagen können, ja fürchterlich.
Ja, aber dann nimmt man doch nicht eine Gesetzesinitiative, die jetzt seit zehn Jahren durchgekaut ist,
die x-mal vom Verfassungsgericht und vom Europäischen Gerichtshof schon abgelehnt wurde.
Also ich meine irgendwann ist das doch auch mal durch.
Also das ist zumindest die Erklärung, die ich gerade gegeben habe, wäre, sag ich mal, systeminherente Erklärung, die jetzt nicht davon ausgeht, dass denen allen irgendwie gezeigt wird übrigens. Welcome to hell!
Ja gut, ich meine das kann ich schon verstehen. Ich meine wir würden uns wahrscheinlich auch nicht besonders gut fühlen in so einer Rolle und dann bist du die erste
Adresse, die angesprochen wird in dem Moment, wo halt irgendwie alles explodiert. Und dann will man irgendwie nicht blöd dastehen. Aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Motivationen,
vielleicht richtige Politik zu machen. Könnte ich mir zumindest mal vorstellen, dass das eine gute Idee wäre.
Naja. Nö.
Ja, absolut.
FRAG DEN STADT hat übrigens auch in anderen Bereichen hier mit pro Asyl mal geschaut. Da gibt es auch zu wenig personelle Änderungen.
Und wenn man sich mit Seehofers Asylpolitik und seiner Freude zum 69. Geburtstag oder was das da war, auseinandersetzt, dann kann man sich auch ungefähr vorstellen, was da für Leute sitzen.
Und das ist ein Problem, wenn du so einen Laden übernimmst. Da brauchst du halt einen eisernen Besen.
Da hast du erstmal die Kontinuität im Haus.
Zwei direkt zu Beginn.
Ja, das ist natürlich schwierig.
Oder halt irgendwie eine andere Methode, mit der man dann so seine Richtlinienpolitik durchgesetzt bekommt. Dazu müsste man sich halt dann alles genau anschauen. Das erfordert dann wiederum eine große Fachkenntnis und eine große Anstrengung.
Aber nach Fachkenntnis werden diese Ministerien ja auch nicht notwendigerweise vergeben.
Nein, nicht unbedingt.
Neues von der Gematik. Die Gematik hat am Donnerstag, den 8. Dezember, die Spezifikation für Konnektoren geändert.
Und in dieser neuen Spezifikation ist jetzt die Option der Laufzeitverlängerung von Konnektoren Software Update verpflichtend umzusetzen.
Kontext, wir reden jetzt vom Gesundheitssystem und der Anbindung der digitalen Anbindung von allen Teilnehmern daran.
Wir reden von dem Thema, über das wir hier mit Flübcke gesprochen haben, was wir seitdem hier auch regelmäßig behandeln, nämlich, dass die Konnektoren mit Zertifikaten versehen sind. Diese Zertifikate laufen,
ab, wie es gute Art ist bei Zertifikaten. Und das nehmen die Hersteller, insbesondere einer,
die CGM, Computer Group Medical, zum Anlass, den kompletten Gerät zu tauschen, statt dem ein neues,
Zertifikat auszustellen und das per Software Update einzupflegen. Und das war möglich,
weil es in der Spezifikation nicht verlangt wird, diese Option zu ermöglichen. Da hatten die,
Hersteller in der Gematikrunde ein paar Monate vorher gegen gestimmt, dass man so was macht.
Ich meine, wenn du eine geplante Obsoleszenz hast, dann schreibst du dir hier eine Spezifikation,
dass du die wegkriegst mit einem Softwareupdate. Das ist ja verrückt. Und wenn man dann fragst, natürlich mit den Herstellern genau die richtigen, die wissen, eine objektive Entscheidung zu fällen.
Naja, und jetzt steht es da eben drin, aber keine Sorge, es kommt natürlich viel zu spät, weil jetzt steht das zwar in der Spezifikation drin, aber jetzt muss noch eine Finanzierungsvereinbarung irgendwie getroffen werden. Wie man das denn hier hinkriegt, mit anderen Worten, das kommt zu spät,
und wird dann wohl die aktuellen wahrscheinlich nicht mehr betreffen, weil die Zertifikate ausgelaufen sind, bis sie da irgendwie vernünftig was gemacht haben. Mit der TI 2.0, die dann,
2025 kommen soll, braucht man dann eh keine Konnektoren mehr. Also es ist natürlich sinnvoll, jetzt noch mal schnell für die letzten zwei Jahre den Leuten neue zu verkaufen. Es läuft ja Spitze, das läuft eigentlich nach Plan. Und dann gibt es aber jetzt immerhin, was ich sehr, sehr.
Heißt das, dass die Leute jetzt doch ihre Konnekturen noch austauschen müssen, obwohl man sie per Software updaten kann?
Schön finde. Naja, das muss ja erstmal jemand machen. Also bis jetzt hat ja noch keiner gesagt,
das wird umgesetzt. Also bis jetzt hat noch keiner den Code geschrieben. Und bis sie das alles umgesetzt haben, werden auf jeden Fall mindestens die ersten Konnektoren schon
sicherlich abgelaufen sein.
Das heißt irgendwann gibt es dann das Software Update und ab dann müssen die Leute nicht was neues kaufen und die, die früher gekauft haben, haben dann sozusagen die Arschkarte und werden sich richtig aufregen und dann klagen.
Also die ersten sind jetzt zum Beispiel schon abgelaufen.
Laut CGM laufen die ersten...
Sind die ersten jetzt schon September abgelaufen. Hier gibt es auch eine schöne CGM.
Gemäß der Beschlüsse der Vertreterversammlung und der Gematik müssen die TI-Hardwarekomponenten, deren Zertifikate bis August 2023 ablaufen, gegen neue Komponenten getauscht werden.
Lalalala, Austausch wurden betrachtet, Ergebnis alternativlos.
Das ist ja die Argumentation von CGM.
August 23 hast du gesagt.
Nein, ich habe August 23 gesagt, bis spätestens.
Die werden ja hergestellt und dann kriegen die mit der Herstellung ein Zertifikat.
Die werden ja nicht alle an einem Tag hergestellt und nicht alle an einem Tag provisioniert.
Deswegen ist es bei CGM so, dass die offenbar die ersten September 22 auslaufen und die letzten August 23.
Also in diesem Zeitraum laufen die offenbar ab.
Da bin ich mir jetzt aber richtig verarscht vorkommen als äh...
Ja, sicher kannst du dir völlig verarscht vorkommen.
Da konntest du dir von Beginn an völlig verarscht vorkommen.
Die Folge mit Flipke sei hier herzlich noch mal nahegelegt, aber es ist tatsächlich so, ja, also jeder, alle Geräte können, also wenn man zertifiziert, wenn wir, stell dir mal vor,
Google müsste jedes Mal ihre Serverfarm wegwerfen, wenn ein Zertifikat abgelaufen ist.
Allein das erklärt ja schon, dass es potenziell eine Lösung dafür gäbe. Und jetzt haben, wer das alles ist, das ist ausgeschwärzt, das sind also sieben Zahnärzteverbände,
haben eine Anzeige bei der Antikorruptionsstelle, also an den Leiter der Stelle zur Bekämpfung von Fehlverhalten im Gesundheitswesen,
gemäß § 197a SGBV des GKV-Spitzenverbands.
Sie haben eine Anzeige quasi geschrieben, das ist jetzt keine Strafanzeige, sondern eine Meldung bei der Antikorruptionsstelle,
und sagen hier, unnötig entstehen mehr Ausgaben beim Connectortausch
in Höhe von 72 Millionen Euro,
allein im Zeitraum 1. September, 22. bis 31. März 23,
und tragen da auch noch mal die Argumentation vor,
Insbesondere Compute Group Medical.
Ursächlich hierfür ist die fehlende Umsetzung der Spitzigifikation zur Laufzeitverlängerung und so weiter.
Und lassen da jetzt mal wegen. Weil quasi die Idee selber, dass man das machen sollte, das wurde ja von denen.
Das haben die Gärtner ja selber den Bock abgeschossen, wie man das sagt. Und da melden sie sich jetzt mal wegen Korruption, weil das wäre ja wirklich auch erstaunlich.
Also wenn die das entschieden hätten, ich meine, da bist ja dein Job los. Wenn deine Cashcash ist, dass du diese Konnektoren verkaufst und du hast eine Garantie, den gleichen
Idioten noch mal einzuverkaufen und dann gehst du in der Gematik treffen und sagst, mach mal mit einem Software-Update und du lässt dir diese 72 Millionen entgehen, da wirst ja gefeuert.
Kannst ja nicht bringen.
Ja klar. Und das ist den Zahnärzten hier auch aufgefallen. Die wissen ja auch, dass sie regelmäßig mal einen Zahn ziehen müssen, um das Geschäft am Laufen zu halten.
Und deswegen haben die sich jetzt hier beschwert.
Also das wird noch lustig. Und die tragen natürlich ähnlich im Wesentlichen die Argumentation vor, die es schon seit längerem
gibt und die durch die Argumentation von dem Team von Heise und dann nochmal durch die Demonstration von Flippke eben auch der Lüge gestraft wurde.
Na schauen wir mal, auf jeden Fall dürfte die Meldung.
Aber keine Sorge, das läuft schon alles langsam genug, dass da schon noch die Kohle wird schon noch gemacht. Da müssen wir uns jetzt keine Sorgen machen.
Werden die jetzt noch ein paar Formfehler, Abhängigkeiten, Prüfungen oder so was machen. So leicht lassen die sich das nicht nehmen.
Wir haben den Kampf ja lange genug geführt.
Dass man das irgendwie alles auch per Software machen kann, für eine ganze Menge Aufregung gesorgt haben in der Branche.
Also, ich muss das tatsächlich sagen, darauf haben mich Ärztinnen und Ärzte schon vor,
sehr langer Zeit angesprochen und angeschrieben, die dann so meinten, ja hier, da müssen wegen Zertifikaten sollen Geräte getauscht werden.
Also hätte man vielleicht auch früher noch eskalieren können, gebe ich durchaus zu, haben die Zahnärztinnen und Zahnärzte ja aber gemacht, die haben das ja eskaliert.
Die haben das ja vorgetragen, haben gesagt, hier, das kommt uns komisch vor, was hier
erzählt wird und so weiter.
Und das haben die dann einfach ausreichend lange ausgesessen, die Compute Group Leute.
Tricky.
Die wissen schon, wie man das macht.
Ja. So läuft's.
Los, Twitter. Wir müssen.
Ja, erzähle Tim, was Neues.
Das ist furchtbar.
Der Niedergang setzt sich fort. Elon Musk scheint immer noch völlig neben der Tasse zu sein. Keine Ahnung. Also ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher,
ob er jetzt wirklich eher so evil ist oder ob ein psychologisches Problem vorliegt.
Also vielleicht auch beides, das kann natürlich auch sein, aber das ist schon irgendwie alles nicht mehr nachzuvollziehen. Also es ist in einem totalen Trollmodus, so einem Dauertrollmodus,
ich weiß noch gar nicht, ob der Mensch überhaupt noch Schlaf kriegt. Auf jeden Fall scheint er sich nicht mehr sehr viel mit seinen anderen Unternehmen zu beschäftigen, sondern irgendwie nur mit Twitter. Musste jetzt aber auch wieder Tesla-Aktien verkaufen, damit er irgendwie nur genug Kohle hat, um das irgendwie in Twitter reinzupumpen, weil offensichtlich ist das jetzt so ein
richtig schönes Grab. Wie sagtest du so schön vorhin, irgendwie so vom Milliardär zum Millionär?
Twitter macht Elon Musk zum Millionär.
Genau, das wäre natürlich schön, aber bis dahin will er auf jeden Fall alle noch für
irgendwas bestrafen und die ganze Bestrafung der vollständigen Twitter-Community, die hat sich.
Weiter fortgesetzt, so. Also, obwohl er ja irgendwie der Meinung war, er wäre jetzt hier
irgendwie der Botschafter von Free Speech und überhaupt alles blühende
Landschaften und so weiter, ist er jetzt erstmal damit beschäftigt, seine ganzen
Kritiker zu sperren auf seiner Plattform. Das ist natürlich auf der einen Seite eine ganze Menge Journalisten, aber auch linke Gruppen, die irgendwie
ihren Account geblockt bekommen haben, ohne dass groß irgendeine Argumentation
dafür geliefert wurde. Nachdem sich die Journalisten alle öffentlich auf ihren eigenen Kanälen darüber aufgeregt haben, wurden dann Teil von denen auch wieder
freigeschaltet, weil, haben halt einen Kanal und das ist ja dann irgendwie dann
doch ein bisschen peinlich, aber eben beileibe nicht alle und so geht das jetzt
die ganze Zeit hin und her. Naja und das hat natürlich dann dazu geführt, dass sie dann irgendwie alle in zunehmendem Maße auf Alternativen
verweisen und auf andere Plattformen und wo dann auch noch irgendwie diskutiert werden kann und das führt dann zu weiteren Eskalationen. Da kommen wir
gleich noch zu. Bleiben wir vielleicht erstmal bei dieser Geschichte, was eigentlich mit den
Journalisten war. Die hatten nämlich vor allem auch über den Account ElonJet berichtet. ElonJet ist ein Twitter-Account, der immer über die Whereabouts von Elon Musks Privatflugzeug berichtet.
Sprich, der ermittelt sich die Position dieses Flugzeuges, die nicht wirklich öffentliche Information ist und hat die dann irgendwie getwittert. Und das ärgert ja Elon Musk schon
seit langem, obwohl er ja am Anfang meinte so, naja also ich bin ja hier so total free,
speech und ich würde ja noch nicht mal den Typen sperren, der die ganze Zeit die Koordinaten von meinem Flugzeug postet, nur dass er das natürlich jetzt trotzdem gemacht hat.
Also er hat das sehr sehr pathetisch.
My commitment to free speech extends even to not banning the account following my plane,
even though that is a direct personal safety risk.
Genau, und er hat ihn gesperrt, er hat aber auch den Typen, der hinter diesem Account
ist, also auch dessen privaten Account, auch noch gesperrt und dann hat er irgendwie alle
gesperrt, die auch nur darüber geredet haben. Und das ging irgendwie völlig durch die Decke, die ganze Geschichte.
Die darüber berichtet haben.
Der Tweet, den ich gerade vorgelesen habe, hat jetzt so eine wunderschöne, also das
ist ja allein das, der hat so eine wunderschöne Fact-Checking-Box. The implied account in this Tweet is Elon Jett, which is currently banned.
Also das steht jetzt quasi unter dem Tweet, wo er sagt, hier, ich bin beide free speech,
selbst den werde ich nicht bannen. Steht halt drin, hat er übrigens gebannt.
Also das ist so ein absoluter, also was für ein Trainwreck, oder?
Es ist total absurd. Was allerdings an diesem Hinweis, den du gerade erwähnt hast, auch noch steht, ist Elon Jett used to,
use publicly available plane tracking data to follow which airports must private jet flew to.
Und das ist richtig und vielleicht auch nicht ganz so richtig. Also vielleicht soll man das noch mal kurz aufblättern.
Alle Flugzeuge, die heutzutage auf der Welt unterwegs sind, senden permanent bestimmte Informationen über ihren Flug über so einen Broadcast-Kanal auf,
1090 MHz. Man nennt das ADS-B, das steht für Automatic Dependent Surveillance Broadcast und.
ADSB oder?
Ist halt so ein Standard. Und die Flugzeuge senden das halt so sekündlich aus und da sind dann halt so GPS-Daten drin, Flughöhe, die Richtung, Geschwindigkeit, Position, so etwas ist da drin,
kodiert und das Ganze geht natürlich auch noch mit einer ID her. Und alle Linienflugzeuge etc. sind darüber dann auch eindeutig identifizierbar, weil es ein entsprechendes Verzeichnis gibt mit.
Diesen IDs, damit man eben auch weiß, worum es sich handelt, bzw. man findet das dann unmittelbar an dieser ADS Datenbank. Das ist quasi die Quelle, aus der sich solche Portale wie Flightradar24
dort kommen und so weiter bedienen, die ihr sicherlich auf die eine oder andere Art und
Weise schon mal benutzt oder zumindest mal gesehen oder zur Kenntnis genommen habt. Das ist ja auch ganz interessant, um zu gucken, was fliegt eigentlich so weltweit. War auch,
interessant zu sehen, was bei Corona als Corona irgendwie anfing, was dann auf einmal alles
nicht mehr flog und was dann alles bald auch schon wieder flog, nachdem das Thema durch
war, naja. Nun ist es so, dass bestimmte Flugzeuge dort aber so eine Anonymisierung genießen,
Und das betrifft halt so sicherheitssensitive Flüge und auch öffentliche Personen.
Also Privatjets können dort anonym gelistet werden.
Und das war bis 2020 einfach so, dass dann eben zu dieser ID keinerlei Informationen veröffentlicht wurden.
Aber diese Informationen kann man natürlich dann ganz gut korrelieren über die Zeit,
sodass dann eben doch irgendwie klar war, hinter welcher ID welches Flugzeug steckt. Und so war das halt auch bei Elon Musk.
Die FAA hat dann aber dann auch noch die Möglichkeit geschaffen, einen sogenannten
Limited Aircraft Data Displayed Modus zu aktivieren.
Das heißt, ab 2020 konnte man sagen, hier ist jetzt mal für mich echt ein Problem. Und das ist natürlich für Leute, die stark in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, also Prominente
im weiteren Sinne, ist das natürlich auch ein Problem. Dieser Beatles-Effekt, die landen irgendwo und sind dann erst mal so Herrscher an von
Fans oder so, die über dich herfallen. Und das willst du natürlich irgendwie verhindern.
Und ich kann das auch ganz gut verstehen, weil in dem Moment, wo man natürlich stark in Öffentlichkeit steht und sowieso schon unter extremer Beobachtung ist, ist es
natürlich dann auch sehr schwierig, so seine eigene Privatsphäre noch in irgendeiner Form zu erhalten. Kann man jetzt darüber lächeln, ob,
der ganzen Privilegien diese Leute genießen, aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das jetzt nicht unbedingt immer so ein Spaß ist.
Teilweise ja auch.
Sicherheitsimplikationen hat, weil sind ja nicht unbedingt alles immer nur Fans, sondern es können ja genauso gut Leute sein, die einfach eine Kugel in den Kopf schießen wollen.
Gab es ja nun auch schon, John Lennon und so weiter. Also alles problematisch. Was macht jetzt dieses LADD?
Das bedeutet, dass deine ID sozusagen überhaupt nicht öffentlich gelistet ist und sich auch noch regelmäßig ändert. Also das ist so quasi so eine Rolling ID, du kriegst quasi am laufenden Meter wieder eine neue.
Und so ist es dann halt auch bei Elon Musk und seinem Privatjet gewesen oder ist es noch so? Nur, dass jetzt Elonjet, dieser Account von diesem, wer ist der Jack Sweeney oder so, weiß ich gerade nicht genau.
Der hat dann eben, also trotzdem müssen diese Flugzeuge aber ihre Flugpläne veröffentlichen und sagen hier.
JacksViney ist richtig.
Wir wollen von da nach da fliegen. Das heißt, es gibt schon dann doch mal eine öffentliche Komponente. Also man weiß, dass sozusagen dieses Flugzeug will an dem Tag von da nach da fliegen.
Und die Datenbank spuckt also nun unbekannte IDs aus, die dann aber wiederum ganz gut korrelieren,
weil man weiß ja, was für ein Flugzeug das ist, in welcher Flughöhe das fliegt, wie schnell das fliegt, man weiß wann es in etwa wo ist, so dass eben dieses Live-Tracking
dann doch möglich ist, weil man quasi diese ID dann wieder über diese veröffentlichten,
Flugbahndaten dann doch wieder zuordnen kann.
Und damit ist dann eben auch diese frisch gewonnene Anonymität dann auch schon wieder
dahin.
Und es ist jetzt so ein bisschen auch so eine Debatte in diesem ganzen Hin und Her um Elon-Jet, ob es sich sozusagen hierbei wirklich um eine öffentliche Information ist,
die einfach so im Internet rumliegt und dann wird sie ja in Anführungsstrichen nur gepostet,
oder ob es sich nicht hier dann doch um etwas halbwegs verwerfliches handelt, weil man ja im
Prinzip die Privatsphäre einer Person auflöst, die eigentlich durch so eine Teilanonymisierung
der Daten gegeben sein soll. Ja, das ist eine interessante Diskussion, wie ich finde.
Das ist ja auch, muss ich aber auch sagen, Tim, einer der Gründe, dass ich kein Privatjet.
Gerade weil, ich meine, wenn einen das selbst nicht betrifft, okay, so, ja, aber
weiß nicht, wir würden das jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht so geil finden,
wenn jetzt die ganze Zeit Leute so über unsere Whereabouts twittern würden.
Man kennt ja diesen Effekt, dass man irgendwo erkannt wird.
Ja, korrekt.
Es kann aber genauso gut auch dir im ICE passieren, dass da jemand zwei Reihen hinter dir sitzt und du sagst,
ja, der Linus, der fährt aber jetzt gerade hier von da nach da. Und am Bahnhof kommst du an und dann übernimmt irgendjemand anders und,
wird es fotografiert und wird es irgendwie gepostet und das würdest du halt auch nicht geil finden.
Allerdings, also das ist, also ich finde, du hast den Sahfa halt sehr gut wiedergegeben
und das zeigt aber auch sehr genau weshalb die Entscheidung darüber so etwas zu sperren
oder nicht zu sperren, nicht bei Elon Musk liegen sollte, sondern bei irgendjemandem,
der oder die ein Gremium ist, das irgendwie legitimiert ist und sich mit solchen Fragen
auseinandersetzt. Ich weiß, dass es seit längerem diese Debatte um diesen Elon-Jet-Account gibt.
Ich weiß, ich habe da ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht so eine direkte Meinung. Es ist auch ein
bisschen komisch. Der macht das ja auch nicht nur mit dem, sondern auch mit anderen Privatjets. Ich glaube, es gibt auch irgendwie Bill Gates oder so was. Ich weiß nicht genau, wer so die Kollegen sind, die auch noch Privatjet-Flüge die ganze Zeit machen. Ich glaube nur jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt, dass das für den Elon Musk jetzt so ein unmittelbares Risiko ist. Nach meiner Kenntnis hatte John Lennon auch kein Privatjet im Central Park stehen, wo er glaube ich da in der Nähe gewohnt hat oder so. Also ich kann es tatsächlich, ich kann eigentlich.
Also die Entscheidung ist das jetzt in Ordnung oder nicht. Also ich persönlich finde es auch ziemlich egal, wo Elon Musk ist. Der kann ja weltweit die ganze Zeit Schaden anrichten.
Ich habe jetzt nicht unbedingt die höchste Sympathie damit, dass da jemand sich das zum Inhalt macht, den zu verfolgen mit seinem blöden Jet. Das ist auch das einzige Zuhause,
was der Hermann ist, obdachlos. Das muss man auch mal klar sagen. Also der hat kein Zuhause,
der hat keinen festen Wohnsitz. Elon Musk.
Die Lamaska hat keinen festen Wohnsitz.
Nein. Er kann sein, dass er irgendwo noch in einem Briefkasten hängen hat, aber nach meiner
Kenntnis hat er zum Beispiel nicht eine Villa oder so was. Dieses Flugzeug ist das Einzige, was der Mann hat.
Der lebt sozusagen im Flugzeug, so ein Flugzeug-Hobo.
Der fliegt mit dem Flugzeug rum und dann schläft er unter dem Schreibtisch oder so, weil er
jetzt auch sehr viel arbeitet. Worauf ich hinaus will, ist, die Entscheidung darüber sollten irgendwelche Menschen treffen,
diese Entscheidung balanciert treffen. Und Putin vielleicht, ja, ist es richtig oder nicht richtig,
zu sagen, okay, wir bannen diesen Account Elon-Jet, ja. Sicherlich ist es aber nicht in Ordnung,
dann den Betreiber, der spezifisch ja extra einen anderen Account hat, den Privataccount zu löschen
und dann jedem Journalisten, der negativ darüber berichtet, auch noch den Account zu löschen. Ich denke, das ist erkennbar.
Klar, ich meine, das ist alles nicht vertretbar, was Twitter und Elon Musk da machen, weil er halt in so einem vollen Rage-Modus ist und natürlich da auch so seine Privilegien voll ausspielt, auch wenn er den jetzt verklagt.
Und natürlich wäre der Weg, man hätte jetzt sozusagen irgendeine Third-Party-Instanz, die das dann richtet, aber dann weiß er, das gilt dann erst mal nur für die US-Jurisdiktion, wenn jetzt irgendjemand irgendwo auf dem Planeten damit anfängt, was ist dann. Das ist schon schwierig und ich kann auch in gewisser Hinsicht verstehen, dass so ein,
Privacy-Breeching gegen Regeln einer Plattform verstoßen kann.
Er geht natürlich jetzt nicht besonders klug vor und schon gar nicht, wenn er eben auch
noch so einen Kollateralschaden macht. Aber wenn es nur das wäre, könnte man ja darüber lachen, aber jetzt geht es ja irgendwie alles in die nächste Phase, weil natürlich jetzt irgendwie alle sagen so, oh Gott, Twitter,
das, die neue Titanic, jetzt aber mal schneller alle hier in die Rettungsboote und dann halt die
passenden URLs zu ihren neuen Rettungsbooten posten. Und das scheint ihm jetzt wohl irgendwie auch aufgefallen zu sein, dass das stattfindet und ihm jetzt massenweise User abhanden kommen. Keine Ahnung,
ob die das jetzt nur fühlen oder ob die das irgendwie in ihren Zahlen sehen, dass.
Irgendwie, was weiß ich, die Zahl der Posts runtergeht oder hohes Maß an,
Account-Schließungen oder so stattfindet, die nicht von ihnen selbst
ausgelöst wurde. Jetzt ging es los, dass sie halt auch noch,
URLs sperren, die auf Mastodon-Instanzen verweisen. Und vor ein paar Stunden haben
sie sogar eine neue Policy rausgegeben, dass das jetzt sozusagen verboten wäre,
auf andere Social Media Plattformen und andere Accounts zu verweisen. Was natürlich
völlig absurd ist. Also das könnte wirklich jetzt langsam mal wirklich den Untergang von
Twitter einleiten. Also das überschreitet jetzt einfach alles. Das ist auch so dumm,
weil das natürlich einfach Streisand-Effekt zum Kubik ist. Dadurch macht er natürlich enorm auf
andere Plattformen aufmerksam. Meinen meisten Leuten ist wahrscheinlich Macedon bisher wirklich,
ziemlich egal gewesen, aber dadurch, dass das jetzt dadurch auch noch mal so eine Bedeutung bekommt und jetzt sogar mit Accountsperre gedroht wird, wenn man irgendwie nur irgendwie ein paar
Zeichen in seiner Bio haben, die auf irgendein Account im Internet verweisen, ist natürlich,
alles völlig überdreht.
Das ist richtig heftig. Das fing ja vor zwei, drei Tagen an, dass es quasi nicht mehr möglich war, Mastodon-Links zu twittern.
Wir haben die Wunde als Malware erkannt.
Das ist jetzt malware.
Ich habe eigentlich noch gedacht, dass er jetzt einfach damit behauptet, dass man da nicht hin, also dass man nicht auf Mastodon linken dürfe, weil es dort ja dann auch diesen Elon-Jett-Account gibt und dass er den quasi als böse bezeichnen würde.
Aber jetzt hat er sich ja wirklich mit dieser neuen Regelung,
die die Belöße gegeben wirklich zu sagen. Also gilt auch für Facebook und Instagram.
Und ja, ist so. Also,
Ist schon wirklich krass.
Das ist jetzt wirklich krass und es geht natürlich auch in der EU schon alle ziemlich steil,
weil das natürlich im Hinblick auf Antikompetitivitätsgesetze usw. auch problematisch sein kann.
Ich habe sowieso den Eindruck, dass demnächst so eine Gesetzesbreitseite aus der EU kommen kann, die Twitter dann nochmal richtig Ärger macht.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob er so bereit ist, komplett auf Europa zu verzichten an der Stelle als Markt, als Markt, aber das könnte ein bisschen schwierig werden.
Also ich finde es, ich meine, das ist jetzt, das ist faszinierend, der dreht halt einfach
völlig durch und er wird, ich weiß nicht, wohin das führen soll. Das ist wirklich richtig, also auch für ihn glaube ich gerade eine richtig krasse Erfahrung.
Verhält sich halt wie ein absoluter Vollidiot und macht sich da alles kaputt. Der hängt da mit 44 Milliarden in der Nummer drin.
Ich meine, wenn du da mit deiner Psychologenbrille mal draufschaust, also für mich kommt das.
Das darf ich ja immer nicht machen, Tim.
Mittlerweile schon krankhaft rüber. Also das ist doch völlig neurotisch, was er da irgendwie...
Dann kommen ja wieder alle und sagen, ich darf nicht sagen, dass der Trump einen an der Pfanne hat.
Das ist schwierig, ne? So sehen und so sehen.
Weil ich das aus der Ferne gar nicht feststellen kann.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob man da zwei Meinungen haben kann, aber egal. Ach komm, ich meine,
ich bin kein Psychologe und ich merke schon, dass so was nicht stimmt. Also das ist einfach kein normales Verhalten. Und ich meine, er macht jetzt richtig vielen Leuten richtig viel kaputt.
Und zwar jetzt nicht nur den Accountschließungen, sondern ich bin seit, was weiß ich, seit wann
bin ich auf dieser Plattform? Seit Ewigkeiten irgendwie, seit über zehn Jahren, seit Dezember 2007. Genau, ich bin seit 15 Jahren mich auf dieser Plattform. 15 Jahre. Und ich habe Twitter eine
Menge zu verdanken, so als Plattform. Das hat einfach immer sehr gut für mich funktioniert,
ist auch irgendwie Teil meines Digitallebens. Und das heißt nicht, dass ich immer alles gut
fand oder alles richtig fand, was dort passiert ist, aber in The Big Theme of Things hat es für
mich irgendwie ganz gut funktioniert und ich hatte da irgendwie meinen Spaß und da ist natürlich
auch kulturell einfach eine Menge passiert. Und es kann es halt durchaus sein, dass das einfach
innerhalb weniger Wochen und Monate von ihm komplett niedergerungen wird, bis diese Plattform wirklich nur noch ein Schatten ihrer selbst ist oder halt komplett gesperrt, gebannt, verboten,
wird oder eben finanziell sich nicht mehr rechnet, weil er jetzt einfach alle Werbekunden,
komplett weggeschickt hat und dann sitzt sich nicht mehr.
Die rechnet sich glaube ich schon jetzt nicht.
Also der hatte ja, wie war das denn?
Mann, das müsste ich wissen. Der hatte doch... Also er hat das Ding auf jeden Fall schon so stark überschuldet, dass es mehr Einkommen machen muss, als es durchschnittlich davor gemacht hat.
Also quasi die Zinszahlungen und Tilgungsraten, die er quasi eingegangen ist für das Ding, Mit den 13 Milliarden Schulden hat er ja noch auf Twitter selber geworfen.
Und dann haben sich ein paar Dinge ungünstig verschoben, sodass er jetzt seine Kredite
nicht mehr so günstig bekommen hat, wie er die vielleicht gerne gehabt hätte. Und ich glaube, die Tilgungsraten, die er nur auf diese 13 Milliarden hat, sind höher
als das, was Twitter zum Zeitpunkt des Kaufes an Umsatz hatte.
Und das war bevor die Anzeigen Kunden weggerannt sind.
Genau, und ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass es jetzt keinen Pfad gegeben hätte,
den man so vorhersagen könnte, wo man sagt so, ja, da lässt sich Twitter verbessern,
da wird es attraktiver, da nimmt es mehr Geld ein, in irgendeiner Form. Hättest sicherlich eine Menge guter Ideen bekommen, aber irgendwie gegen deine eigene Userbase vorgehen,
alle Leute irgendwie völlig wahnsinnig machen und dann so eine Privatsensur loszutreten, die sich im Wesentlichen auf deine persönliche, also auf dein Leben bezieht.
Und dann so, oh was jetzt, jetzt seid ihr alle angepisst und jetzt wollt ihr auf andere Plattformen ausweichen, jetzt verbieten wir euch das auch noch.
Also dass es ja wirklich so trügelnd im Gefängnis ist.
Ich hoffe halt, dass der irgendwann mal schläft.
Tatsächlich, der befindet sich ja ganz offensichtlich gerade in so einer Art Meltdown. Der ist ja dann auch noch, was hast du dir diese Aufzeichnung angeschaut von diesem Twitter Space, nachdem er dann da die Journalisten, das sind jetzt auch nicht irgendwelche Journalisten,
sondern irgendwie New York Times Kapazitäten, die er da runter geworfen hat.
Die haben ihn einfach mal gefragt, was denn so seine Policy ist und dann hat er dann keinen Bock mehr gehabt und dann ist er aus diesem Space rausgegangen und kurze Zeit später sind alle Twitterspaces ausgeschaltet gewesen.
Das Bass ist ausgemacht.
Ja, das ganze Feature wurde sozusagen abgeschaltet. Meines Wissens läuft es mittlerweile wieder, aber das ist ja einfach so wie so ein kleines Kind, was irgendwie die Tür hinter sich richtig laut zuknallen lässt, damit irgendwie die Eltern auch so richtig Notiz davon nehmen.
Ja, es hat er wieder angemacht.
Wenn das so ein Admin von einer Mastodon-Instanz macht, der jetzt gerade überfordert ist,
kann ich das ja verstehen.
Aber so, und jetzt stell dir vor, du hast halt nicht nur eine Mastodon-Instanz, was,
wie ich mir sagen lasse, äußerst anstrengend ist.
Und mit viel Arbeit, da tanzen dir viele auf dem Kopf rum und haben irgendwie deine Regeln
durchsetzen und so weiter. Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, du hast die, die hat aber noch ein paar Millionen Benutzern
mehr als deine Masterdome Instanz und außerdem hattest du, bevor du das Scheiß dingert, hattest echt ein ganz gutes Leben.
Warst überall wohlgelitten, warst irgendwie der Star, außer halt an der Bergeintür, aber,
Sonst bist du eigentlich überall reingekommen und warst einfach so ein Vorbild für alle. Und bis innerhalb kürzester Zeit einfach so der Vollarsch.
Und ich denke halt, dass er auch einfach nicht die Erfahrung gemacht hat.
Weil doch die Erfahrung muss er eigentlich bei SpaceX hat, hat er ja schon gemacht. dass es sinnvoller ist, die Sachen Leuten in die Hände zu geben, die Ahnung davon haben.
Ja, das geht sicherlich auch für seine anderen Unternehmungen.
Er muss jetzt einfach, entweder er ruiniert das Ding jetzt einfach vollends oder er schafft es, jetzt irgendwie eine ganz, ganz bekannte, besonnene Person, die irgendwie aus dem Tech-Umfeld
große Miriten hat, dazu zu CEO zu machen und lässt den Laden da irgendwie laufen.
Weil er dreht halt einfach gerade durch. Er trifft halt, das ist ja das Schlimme, wenn er jetzt wenigstens Entscheidungen treffen würde, die für ihn gut sind, dann würde ich ja sagen, okay, ist einfach
ein Arschloch. Aber er trifft ja gerade Entscheidungen, die richtig, richtig, also die können nicht,
im Vollbesitz seiner geistigen Kräfte getroffen worden sein.
Und das ist faszinierend dabei zuzuschauen, wie halt dieser Typ einfach öffentlich komplett tiltet,
und sich dann Milliardeninvestment komplett in den Arsch macht.
Und ich möchte noch mal dran erinnern, ich glaube der wollte das Ding auch nicht kaufen.
Ja, also zwischenzeitlich wollte er es auf jeden Fall nicht mehr kaufen, sonst hätte er sich ja nicht so aufgeregt.
Dann musste er es kaufen, weil er schon zu weit vorangeschritten ist, aber deswegen muss er es ja nicht gleich ruinieren. Ich meine, er hätte es ja zumindest auch gleich wieder, er hätte es ja einfach mit Verlust einfach jemand anderes wieder verkaufen können.
Wär billiger geworden.
Ja, das genau ich glaube jetzt
Ja, weil der hat ja noch die 13 Milliarden Schaden.
Jetzt will das schon keiner mehr haben. Also ich meine keine Ahnung, also für ein paar Millionen würde es wahrscheinlich irgendjemand noch nehmen.
Die ehemaligen Mitarbeiter von Twitter.
Ja gut, aber ich meine die sind halt irgendwie weg.
Hat er halt Tesla-Aktien verschenkt.
Auch dass der Jack Dorsey nicht mal hingeht und sagt, Junge, irgendjemand muss doch gerade
noch zudem durchgehen. Also...
Ich weiß nicht, das ist irgendwie, haben die sich so ein Virus eingefangen und das ist diese Krankheit,
die alle irgendwie in diesem Right-Wing-Bereich da in den USA haben. Das ist irgendwie so ein ganz merkwürdiger Genstrang, die dieser Virus hat. Da steckt halt so ein bisschen klassische
rechtsradikale Politik mit drin, so ein bisschen Krypto-Coin-Wesen und einfach so eine merkwürdige
gesellschaftliche Renitenz, dass man wirklich nur noch überall Feinde sieht und eigentlich,
diese Welt nur noch brennen lassen will. Das irre ist, dass das ja einfach zu seinem bisherigen
Standing so überhaupt nicht passt, weil er nun eigentlich mit Tesla gerade irgendwie so den,
Nimbus hatte von ja wir bringen jetzt mal hier irgendwie die Energierevolution richtig nach,
vorne, aber das scheint für ihn auch keine wirkliche Bedeutung zu haben, sondern es war nur so
dieser Aspekt mit, da kann man irgendwie Geld mit verdienen. Also da ist halt wenig Substanz.
Ich glaube, der hat einen akuten Fall von XKCD 386.
3,86.
Ja, muss man.
Und wer den kennt, weiß auch genau Bescheid. Das ist einer der XKCDs, die man auswendig kennen muss.
Und ich glaube, genau so sieht das bei dem gerade aus zu Hause oder in seinem Flugzeug.
Das ist der XKCD, wo das Männchen am Computer sitzt und aus dem Bild raus eine Stimme kommt.
Are you coming to bed? I can't, this is important. What someone is wrong on the Internet?
Und ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich einfach der... jeder kennt diesen Geisteszustand.
Alle hatten ihn schon mal und es ist halt scheiße wenn dich der ereilt wenn du gerade,
Twitter gekauft hast.
Duty Calls. Wenn dich deine Verpflichtung ruft. Nur doof, wenn das sozusagen dein kaputtes alter Ego ist und du dich mit dir selber unterhältst.
Ja, okay, reden wir von weit geringeren Millionen Beträgen, die man verballern kann.
Oh man, ey.
Jetzt reden wir über andere Fails.
Die Luca-App haben wir lange nicht mehr behandelt. Und zwar, seitdem sie jetzt, sie wollen ja jetzt Payment-App werden.
Wir erinnern uns, Luca-App, ein paar Millionen Euro Förderung vom Staat bekommen, um eine Kontaktverfolgungs-App zu machen für die Gastronomie.
Dafür geworben haben die Fantastischen vier, die dafür an der ganzen Kohle beteiligt wurden an dem Unternehmen.
Dann wurde eben durch diese erstens staatliche Förderung, durch die Millionen, die denen dabei geholfen haben, diese App zu bauen und dann auch das Verankern in den Infektionsschutzverordnungen,
wurde quasi dieses Privatunternehmen gewissermaßen mit einer sehr guten Strategie gesegnet, um,
sehr viele Millionen Nutzerinnen zu bekommen, weil der Gastronomie eben gesagt wurde, hier nutzt der Luca-App, Staat empfiehlt das und so weiter, hat das einzige zugelassene App,
und so weiter und so fort. Dann haben sie sich um die Anbindung an die Gesundheitsämter gar nicht ordentlich gekümmert,
sondern haben sich direkt um die darauf folgenden Geschäftsmodelle konzentriert. Das war ja auch das,
wovor wir als CCC von vornherein gewarnt haben. Wir haben gesagt, diese Leute führen etwas anderes
im Schilde. Nämlich sie führen im Schilde die Nutzerbasis, die sie dadurch gewinnen, auf andere
Weise zu monetarisieren. Dann sind sie rumgerannt und haben gesagt, wir haben 40 Millionen Nutzer.
Von denen die Hälfte einmal im Monat die App verwendet, also so was wie 20 Millionen Active
User. Damit konnten sie dann Target Global und die Fintech Gründer Ramin Nirumand und Julian
Teike gewinnen, die in insgesamt nochmal 30 Millionen draufgeworfen haben, um eine Payment App zu bauen. Weil, geile Nutzerbasis, also es ist auf jeden Fall, das habe ich ja auch gesagt, die Nutzerbasis ist ein paar Millionen wert, weil egal, was du für eine App baust.
Du musst erst mal so viele Nutzer bekommen. Und 30 Millionen ist jetzt nicht so viel, allerdings, das ist ja nur Investorengeld, was noch mit oben drauf gekommen ist. Und das Ziel,
was die Luka-App hatte, war 2023 einen Umsatz von mehr als 100 Millionen Euro machen. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie wollen Sie denn diesen Umsatz machen? Sie wollten jetzt also zur Zahl-App werden. Das ist,
jetzt auch nicht das allerklügste Feld ist, um sich 2022 großes Wachstum zu erhoffen.
Also es ist eine Königsdisziplin, weil du natürlich bei Payment prozentual einfach mitverdienst. Und wenn du es da schaffst, große Verbreitung zu bekommen und irgendwie sowas wie PayPal oder Visa
oder Mastercard zu werden, dann hast du natürlich langfristig ausgesorgt. Allerdings ist es nicht so, als würden das nicht auch die ganze Zeit Leute versuchen. Dann kommt aber glücklicherweise das,
Datenschutzrecht und sagt, naja, wenn du den Verwendungszweck dieser App einfach änderst, dann müssen natürlich die Leute, also kannst du nicht einfach sagen, du hast hier eine Kontaktverfolgungs- App runtergeladen, jetzt sind wir eine Payment-App, das heißt, die Leute mussten mit ein paar Klicks.
Die App wiederbeleben. Was diese Millionen User, mit denen die geworben haben, natürlich schon
ein bisschen anders wieder erscheinen lässt. Da haben sie die Investoren wohl ganz gut verarscht, weil sie eben nicht wirklich aktive Nutzer hatten, sondern die umbauen mussten. Die mussten erstmal einwilligen. Das haben natürlich nicht so viele gemacht. Und dann sind sie massiv hingegangen
und haben gesagt, hier, jetzt gehst du ins Restaurant. Und dann muss natürlich irgendwie
auch die Leute dazu bringen, dass die mit dieser App zahlen. Und das ist mir,
letzte Woche passiert. Ich gehe in ein Restaurant, gehe zur Kasse, um irgendwie zu klären,
wie groß der Schaden ist. Und dann hängt da so ein Zettel dran, spare 10 Prozent, wenn du jetzt mit Luca zahlst.
Mhm, hab ich auch schon gesehen.
Mir wurde aber ein schlechtes Angebot gemacht, weil in diesem Artikel lese ich, teilweise
bieten sie sogar 20 Prozent. Und damit helfen sie natürlich jetzt nach, dass die Gäste dann sagen, naja, okay, klar, für 10 Prozent, das wäre in diesem Fall ein Essen mit vielen Leuten, das wäre signifikant,
Geld gewesen.
Ich habe auch echt noch kurz überlegt, da habe ich gedacht, so, ey, hhmm, wäre eigentlich nicht schlecht, jetzt mal zehn Prozent von dem Essen von den Idioten bezahlen zu lassen. Aber dann war es ja irgendwie auch zu viel Ärger und dann haben wir das Essen einfach
so bezahlt. Aber das Spannende ist, diese 30 Millionen, die sind relativ schnell weg, wenn das wirklich
das Beste ist, was dir mit deinem Geld einfällt. Also zehn Prozent ist ein ziemlich ordentlicher Rabatt.
Und glücklicherweise, also laut Businessplan, wollten sie im Dezember, also jetzt, in 9.200
Restaurants vertreten sein. Wenn ihr jetzt davon ausgeht, dass vielleicht ein Drittel der Leute diesen Rabatt in Anspruch,
nimmt, dann bist du bei, sagen wir mal, 3000, mal ganz konservativ, 3000 Essen, von denen
10 bis 20 Prozent pro Tag, dann sind die 30 Millionen relativ schnell durch, je nachdem,
in welchen Restaurants du bist.
Haben Sie aber Glück gehabt, weil von Ihrem Ziel 9.200 Locations zu unterstützen, sind
Sie relativ weit entfernt. Sie haben 150.
150. Und du warst in einem von den 150 und ich war in einem von diesen 150?
150, ja.
So, in der App sind 150 Locations zu finden. Es könnte sein, dass diese Locations-Liste nicht so groß ist. Andererseits ist es auch nicht verwunderlich, dass sie wahrscheinlich in Berlin eine Konzentration
haben, vielleicht dann noch in Hamburg oder München. Also in der App sind es 150 Locations.
Und dann habe ich aber was Lustiges gelernt. Wenn du den QR-Code scannst, kannst du mit PayPal bezahlen. Das heißt, die haben noch nicht mal eine eigene Payment-App offenbar.
Das heißt, da sollte die Marketingkasse dann doch relativ bald leer sein.
Ach, man macht nicht das Payment wirklich mit der App, sondern...
Ich habe es, wie gesagt, selber nicht ausprobiert, weil ich keinen Bock hatte, mich bei denen zu registrieren.
Ja, ist auch nicht.
Aber das ist es mir dann nicht wert, wie gesagt, das wäre die 10-20% Rabatt. tatsächlich schon eine Frechheit, dass mir nur 10 Prozent angeboten werden. Also wenn woanders 20 Prozent gibt.
Für den Ärger, den du damit hattest.
Und dann haben sie außerdem noch irgendein Trick, dass sie ein Teil davon, also dass sie das Trinkgeld verdoppeln und dadurch machen sie es natürlich dann,
Also, ist ja nicht blöd. Dadurch machen sie natürlich die Bedienung zu ihrer besten Promoter-Crew.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen, weil ich hatte nämlich in dem Laden, wo ich war, schon, also
die haben es mir so richtig, na aufgedrängt ist vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen ein großes Wort, aber beim Bezahlvorgang das als Option da gereicht. Und da habe ich mich gefragt.
Ja, 10 Prozent mehr Trinkgeld von Luca für deine Lieblingskennerin.
Was sie eigentlich davon haben, aber wenn du sagst Verdopplung des Trinkgeldes,
dann ist das natürlich ein Feature. Das wird teuer.
Naja, aber Leute, also ich finde es schön zu sehen, wie die das jetzt halt trotzdem
verkacken.
Also...
Ja, kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es irgendeinen Erfolg haben wird. Ich meine,
wer will schon ein Payment jetzt extra nur für Restaurants haben? Vor allem sie
reden auf ihrer Webseite von 1000 irgendwelchen Vorteilen, die das haben
soll, können die aber nicht wirklich benennen. Ja, digital und alles irgendwie
ganz einfach. So, aber was ist denn jetzt eigentlich der Vorteil?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht so richtig verstanden. Okay, Trinkgeld ist voreingestellt.
Du kriegst auch noch Luca-Points, wir alle wissen, wenn eins in unserem Leben eine große
Rolle spielt, dann die Herzchen von Kaufland oder was. Wollten wir irgendwie...
Ja, das stimmt. Digitalisierung, die entlastet für schnelleren Service und zufriedeneres Personal. Weil, warum, weswegen? Weniger Laufwege, mehr Zeit für deine Gäste. Aha. Wodurch? Weil ein Telefon benutzt wird oder was?
Hier, warte mal, Bezahlvorgang ohne Kartenterminal, das ist natürlich ganz gut. Also hier, Bezahlvorgang direkt in der App ohne Kartenterminal.
Das ist doch vollkommen irrelevant.
Kartenterminal kostet halbmonatliche Miete. Mehr Trinkgeld durch Voreinstellungen.
Ja, aber Kartenterminal.
Digitalisierung des Städters, weniger Laufwege. Wieso weniger Laufwege?
Ja, aber du kannst auf deinen Kartenterminal sowieso nicht verzichten. Also das ist doch vollkommen absurd.
Und es ist höchster Sicherheit standard und cutting edge Technologie.
Mhm.
Made in Europe, das heißt sie haben jetzt auch schon nach,
irgendwo in andere Teile Europas Outgos. Egal! Also schön, ich freue mich, die,
fahren das immer noch gegen die Wand und das ist auch nicht schlimm.
Also es wäre schlimmer gewesen, wenn die damit auch noch Erfolg gehabt,
hätten. Insofern finde ich es erfreulich, dass sie jetzt halt ein paar
Leuten das Essen bezahlen. Das ist ja in Zeiten der Inflation auch nicht
schlecht, wenn man da mal ein Restaurantessen bezahlt bekommt aus irgendeiner Investoren Kohle und dann damit den Laden ruiniert.
Vielleicht noch mal hingehen, vielleicht bezahle ich doch damit. Vielleicht gehe ich jetzt nochmal bei ein richtig fettes Essen, so für ein paar Millionen Essen, damit das Budget leer ist.
Aber okay, kriegen Sie nicht hin. Ist doch schön.
Wie all diese CEOs ihren eigenen Laden ruinieren.
Das scheint ja so ein Trend zu sein.
Ja, stimmt.
Das wäre ja so, als wenn wir dazu aufrufen würden, für andere Leute zu spenden.
Du hast doch gar nicht gesagt, dass du die Zeit verabschiedest, um zu können, wenn du dich fällst. Dann noch mal. Haha.
So was wird wer niemals tun.
Du hast auch noch einmal die Zeit verabschiedet, um zu können, wenn du dich fällst. Ja, genau. Hahaha.
Du warst auch nur einmal. Jetzt sitzt man da und denkt, das ist ja scheiße.
Du hast auch noch einmal die Zeit verabschiedet, um zu können, wenn du dich fällst. Ja, schön. Können wir Luca Pay machen?
Also Leute, kauft noch ein Shirt und ansonsten wünschen wir euch...
Können wir die Preise um 10% erhöhen?
Achso, meinst du, wenn man das T-Shirt mit Luca-Pack kauft, dann kann man auch noch noch Trinkgeld geben, das wird dann noch verdoppelt. Mal gucken.
Das wäre eigentlich keine schlechte Idee, oder?
Ja, müssen wir uns nur so als Gastronomie irgendwie, naja, egal, scheiß Idee. Leute.
Das war's für heute.
Wir machen jetzt hier Schluss. Ja, ich weiß nicht, was soll man jetzt noch sagen? Jetzt Das kann man noch gar nicht sagen. Weihnachten ist noch nicht, Jahresende ist auch noch nicht.
Bei uns dürfen wir noch für unsere Mastodon-Accounts werben.
Bei uns geht das. Oder, also noch ist es nicht verboten.
Das ist ja eh unsere Plattform.
Wir machen, was wir wollen.
Ja, aber nicht, dass, also dann, aber, also, pass auf, ihr dürft jetzt, also diese, genau, ihr dürft nicht den Link zu dieser Sendung twittern, weil dieser Sendungswerbung für Mastodon...
Oh, man, ist das, ist das fast, vielleicht wird der einfach mal, Vielleicht muss ich jetzt einfach mal ein schönes Weihnachten im Kreis der Familie twittern,
Und dann geht es ihm auch wieder besser.
Ich habe wenig Hoffnung, aber wir schauen mal, wie sich das so entwickelt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine der absurdesten Geschichten in diesem ganzen Tech-Business
und es ist ja auch nicht arm an absurden Geschichten. Ich bin nur froh, dass das Podcast damit nicht totgemacht werden kann.
Dass das Podcast irgendwie noch nicht auf irgendeiner Plattform sind, wo irgendein durchgedreht das CEO alles kaputt machen kann, das finde ich dann doch irgendwie ganz beruhigend.
Naja, ich hab schon manchmal Angst, dass du durchdrehst.
Wer weiß?
Aber bisher ist es noch nicht passiert. Ja, und du denkst, du bist frei von solchen Gefahren?
Bisher ist es nicht passiert. Nee, aber ich bin nicht CEO der Meta-Ebene.
Ach so, ja, ne, aber keine Ahnung.
Noch nicht. Gucken, vielleicht graue ich den irgendwie.
Aber wenn du mal durchdrehst, dann ist auch alles vorbei, Dinos.
Wenn ich mal durchdrehe, dann wirkt Elon Musk wie ein zahmes Kätzchen.
Ja. Es ist wichtig, dass wir unsere geistige Sanität behalten. Ganz wichtig.
Ich versuchte, also ich gebe mir da immer, ich bin stets bemüht.
Also das ist mir auch wirklich wichtig. wirklich wichtig. Also ich habe schon irgendwie so viele Looney's total ausflippen sehen, wo ich mich manchmal auch frage, was ist schief gelaufen? Wo habt ihr die Abbiegungen nicht bekommen? Wo habt ihr die Ampel nicht gesehen? Kann es denn so schwer sein, einfach mal einen klaren Kopf zu
behalten? Offensichtlich scheint das schwer zu sein. Wir wünschen euch auf jeden Fall sehr viel.
Genau, und damit wünschen wir euch schönes Shopping bei der Einhorn-Standarte und schönen.
Glück dabei auch den klaren Kopf zu behalten. Ihr hört ja schon mal das
richtige Programm dafür. Insofern seid ihr schon mal ganz gut aufgestellt.
Oder wohin auch immer.
Umzug nach Mastodon.
Bis später. Tschüss.